-Our next guest is a comedian
and actress who created,
wrote, and stars
in the critically
acclaimed series "Starstruck."
The first two seasons are
streaming now on HBO Max.
Let's take a look.
-Why did you send me a letter?
-No, no, no.
Okay, so, I may have sent
a few letters to people
when I thought I was leaving
the country forever.
-And what sort of emotional
space were you in at the time?
-[ Sobbing ]
Not a great one.
-Please welcome to the show
Rose Matafeo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Hello!
-Welcome to the show, Rose.
-Thanks for having me.
-This is a fantastic show
with just a wonderful premise.
-Oh, yes, wonderful.
-You have a one-night stand
with someone,
not realizing
that they're a movie star.
-Yes, she's not
wearing her glasses.
-Yeah.
-That's what I say.
-That's a beautiful twist.
-Beautiful twist
that I put her in.
-But that sounds like such
a wonderful idea.
Was it an idea
that you always had?
Was it the first idea you had?
-It was not.
Well, well, well, I pitched
a bunch of ideas
for shows that I could
potentially be in myself,
and they were all
deeply rejected
by every channel in the U.K.
And then, on the way back
to New Zealand from London,
I was on a long flight.
It's a very long flights,
it's like 24 hours.
And my agent was like,
"Just please,
just pitch one more thing."
And I was quite drunk,
And I was like, "Well, maybe
I'm in a rom-com, then."
[ Laughs ]
And then I wrote
like a page of stuff,
and, yeah,
that's where it started.
I made all the people on
the plane act it out.
I was very disruptive.
[ Laughter ]
IT was like,
"Get her off the flight."
But, yeah.
-It paid off.
And, you know, so, it's about
this relationship between
these two characters, and your
boyfriend in the show
gets stopped a lot
because he's famous.
And now two seasons
of a very wonderful show,
are you getting stopped at all?
-It's very generous
of you to ask.
[ Laughter ]
I -- it did happen,
because it happened recently,
like, about two weeks ago.
Was Saint Patrick's Day.
I was here in New York.
-Yeah, right place to be.
-Whoa!
-Yeah.
-You guys go hard.
We had a couple of years
with no parades.
-Really?
-Yeah, so we had
to bring them back.
-I had this wonderful thing
where the parade was going on,
and then a perpendicular parade
was happening of angry
New Yorkers trying
to cross the street.
Yeah.
-It was -- it the real New York.
It was great,
but I walked out of a cafe,
and this girl, God bless her,
the drunkest girl
I've ever seen in my life,
she was walking down
the street.
She turned around, and she was
like, "'Starstruck'!"
[ Laughter ]
"'Starstruck,' when is the next
series out?"
And I was like, "Next week."
She was like,
"Good, see you there."
[ Laughter ]
And I was, like, I cannot tell
you how little
her eyes were open
to even recognize me.
And it was so sweet that I got
recognized by --
and it was really weird.
-That's the level of fame
you're at now.
[ Laughter ]
The eye doesn't even have
to be fully open.
-She sensed me.
She sensed I was around,
but, you know...
-So, obviously, you're from
New Zealand, live in London.
When was the last time
you were in New York City?
-The last time?
I'm an adult now.
-Yeah.
-But I wasn't before.
That was a weird way
to get into a story.
I was 16 when I was here last.
-Okay.
-I was on a school history trip.
-Oh, wow.
-I do not know how
we related it
to history in any way,
but it was amazing.
I was 16, and it was like
mid-2000, and the teachers
let us as, 16-year-old girls,
all girls school,
just roam about
New York city alone...
-Yeah.
...for an entire day.
I think, because Ms. Carter,
who was running the trip,
she was really into
"Project Runway"
at that time, and she really
wanted to go to Mood Fabrics.
-Okay.
-And so she was like,
"Girls, enjoy the city."
And I got lost in Macy's.
[ Laughter ]
My friends put a missing-person
report at Macy's for me,
which is apparently a thing.
And they drew, like, a cartoon
of me to try and describe me.
[ Laughter ]
-How long were you lost?
-Seven hours.
[ Laughter ]
No, not long at all.
It was really weird.
-Long enough for a drawing?
-It was really weird.
But, yeah, that was fun.
So now, yeah, I've had a much
more adult time in New York.
-Yeah, that's good.
I hope nobody's letting
you go to Macy's alone.
-I know.
[ Laughter ]
People recognize me at Macy's.
Alright?
They know who I am.
-So, there are obviously
some really lovely New Zealand
elements in the show.
Scrumpy hands
was not a thing.
When I heard this, I did not
know what Scrumpy hands was.
I'm gonna assume
a lot of people here don't.
Explain Scrumpy hands.
-No one knows what Scrumpy hands
is, beyond like
10 people in New Zealand.
No, it is a New Zealand thing.
It's a New Zealand tradition,
a great tradition,
where you take two very cheap
bottles of cider
and duct-tape them
to a hand each,
and you have to drink them
until they're finished.
And that's our culture.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-It's sort of like a party.
It's like a sort
of a party thing.
-Yeah, well, I would hope
it's not a work thing.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I know, it's such
a church thing, as well.
Yeah, I learnt that at church.
-What does "Scrumpy" refer to,
though?
-Scrumpy is a brand of cider.
-Okay, gotcha.
-I'm sponsored by Scrumpy,
obviously.
[ Laughter ]
-We do need you to say
"hashtag ad" after everything.
-Hashtag add.
Hashtag on Scrumpy.
[ Laughter ]
Scrumpy hands, great.
-There's a really wonderful,
deeply funny
pregnancy-test scene
in the show.
-Yes, yes, and serious,
too, yeah, yeah, yeah.
-When you write
something like that,
when you get that idea, are you
like, "Oh, this is a winner"?
-Yeah, well, there the --
the worst thing about that
was, a lot of people were
commenting on it being like,
"This is hilarious.
What an idiot this character is.
Oh, my goodness."
And especially someone reading
a premise which is wrong.
And I was like,
"That's straight.
That happened.
Uhh, complete.
Like, there was no acting.
It was a re-creation.
It was a re-creation of me
reading a pregnancy test wrong,
bursting into tears,
realizing I just read
the wrong lines, and moving on
as if nothing happened, like,
just recovering so quickly.
[ Laughter ]
And that's the weird thing,
is that people watch the show
and they're like,
"Jessie is an idiot."
And I'm like, "Yeah, she is."
[ Laughter ]
"What's she doing
all that stuff for?"
So it's a bit close
to the bone sometimes.
-You've done stand-up comedy,
but you were on television
at a very young age,
sort of before your stand-up.
So, what age is it?
What's "Sticky T.V."
-Who are your researchers?
Because that's the deepest cut
of all time.
I started stand-up
when I was 15,
but when I was 12,
I worked at
a children's television show,
as I gave advice
to other children.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-It was so weird.
-Yeah.
-A 12-year-old taking advice
from an 11-year-old.
-Yeah.
-Like, it was bizarre.
And I used to open fan mail
at the production company
after school.
Really weird.
One kid sent in fingernail
clippings and dried chilies.
-That was what he sent
in his fan mail?
-For one of the female
presenters.
-Okay, gotcha.
And then he went on a list,
I'm hoping?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah.
No, I'm going out with him now.
[ Laughter ]
I keep track of him.
No, yeah, it was really weird,
it was really weird.
-And you also, you know,
obviously, this would count,
the technical term
for what you're doing
about your show is a junket.
You're going out, you're getting
interviewed about your show.
But you were on this side
with American actors
not too long ago.
-Not too long ago.
When I was like early 20s,
I interviewed people.
I interview -- for New Zealand
television, I did, like,
Amy Poehler and Amy Schumer
and Bill Hader,
and it's very --
it's very weird.
The funniest thing, though,
is that I would do bits.
Like, I'd do bits
like I'd speed-date them.
So I'd bring, like,
a mini little table,
a restaurant table,
and, like, be dressed up.
And then I'd, at one point,
be like,
"Do you have any questions
for me?"
To, like, literal celebrities.
The best thing
is that when I did
Bill Hader, it was really fun.
At the end, he was like,
"Yeah, when they told me
about this, I thought
it'd be really bad,
but I was actually
kind of okay."
[ Laughter ]
I was 22, and I was like,
"Thank you, Bill Hader."
[ Laughter ]
I was so nervous.
Yes, it's worse
being on this side.
-I agree with you.
-How are you doing?
Does anyone ask you questions?
-No.
-Are you doing okay?
-I'm okay now.
-Okay, we need to go.
We need to wrap it up.
-We're gonna wrap it up.
-We need to wrap that up.
-Hey, thank you so much.
Congratulations on the show.
It's really lovely meeting you
and having you here.
Guys, that's Rose Matafeo.
"Starstruck" is streaming now
on HBO Max.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."